lassana vous faisiez quoi moment où
coulibaly et est entré dans l'hyper
cacher un courrier rentrée moi j'étais
désert ozerov ce descendant dans nos
réserves pour estoquer le commandent
qu'on avait réussi avec mon collègue
dewan on a mis tous les commandes dans
les rayons les restes de commandes comme
il sait déjà qu'ils aient fini à 13
heures qui m'a dit de décembre pouvez
vous pourrez stocker en définisse de
rentrer à la maison
moi sur des 110 kw à 10 minutes après
que les tories si les représentants du
bruit dans le magasin là vous entendez
un bruit vaut vous restez en bas vous
faites quoi ce serait sympa quand
j'entends des bruits je me suis arrêté
pour savoir ça vient d'où ces bruits
c'est ici d'écouter ce qui se passe en
haut
voilà je me suis arrêter ben moi ce que
j'ai pensé je crois que c'était c'est un
pneu qui a expliqué qu'à ses
périphériques ou un accident vous ai
pensé ça en plus tard encore quelques
boulettes issa répétait plusieurs
reprises sa ces moments qu'ils aient
voyait tous les clients commencent à
descendre dans la réserve il disait que
les touristes sont totalement alors vous
vous connaissiez très bien les lieux qui
je vous avais fait quand vous êtes rendu
compte que c'était une prise d'otage qui
les personnes descendent et qui vous ont
dit il ya un terroriste ya qui rentrait
dans le magasin des vacances sont
descendus pauvres pour lui faire calmer
parce qu'ils ont mis le trouver sans
phase l'escalet qui donnent leurs
réserves séné scanner que le maçon il ya
une personne qui peut descendre mais
avec la foule des personnes ces
traumatismes des arts mais moi ça m'a
des avoirs voir ces personnes sama ça
m'a fait tellement de mal parce que ce
sont des vins rouges quoi quand on voit
leurs visées sont la peur et angoisse
quand ils sont descendus en même temps
descendent en bas on avait mis une
palette heures
je sens face durant face d'escalier en
descendant ils ont fait bousculer des
palettes en bail avec est devant nous
l'effet qu'almeida bozizé fait quand il
faut il faut qu'on se calmeront pourront
trouver la solution parce que les façons
que vous êtes des 110 ans on se met tous
comme ça nous mêmes on va se faire mal
avant que d'être agressé la rive
maintien déjà la portée par des soldats
ils étaient déjà ouverts parce que les
hollandais les cartons se rentre avec
certaines personnes ne passent que en
bois ya des liens on à décembre en bas
sans le conciliateur et ça me ferait là
haut mettez les yaourts les salles est
certain qu'ils sont rentrés la loi du
coup moi se rendre avec eux certains
personnes
vous avez été les mêmes la porte vers
l'intérieur pour protéger quelques beats
il est heureux s'il envoyé ma collègue
marie de venir récupérer l'accueil du
magasin casa pas entendu les pieds
d'escalier quelques mois sa 2 semblent
s'esquisser personnes s'ouvrir les
portes discrètement pour savoir ce qu'il
a personne brisebois et zari qui demande
la clé du magasin mais c'est à moi
n'avait pas la clé parce que j'ai pas le
droit de garder clé mais en descendant
les clients et avait aussi monté radio
c'est qu'il était descendu mais n'était
pas avec nous c'était parti s'est cassé
dernier palette j'ai appelé lady sa mère
est ce que vous talent et à la clé
sautoir il m'a dit oui c'est récupérer
ces données hasard et même en ce moment
et aimant nazaire et c'est quoi si ce
n'est plus au stade où ces sept
braquages pourquoi et aimant la clé même
dit wade est malade mais pour fermer les
magasins on a donné à clé à les monter
dix minutes après encore il en voit
encore des emplois des événements nous
appeler parce que quand il y aura des
dalles maladie la vie des as qui décline
son descendant bas ils viennent nous
appeler il disait j'ai trop monter vous
non moi c'était pas monter si tard et
cela après il disait de monter là-haut
surmonte pas il va faire de carnage il
tient tous les ans à dos et 200 en boire
c'est là et encore il y avait beaucoup
de panique les uns commencent à poser
question qu'est ce qu'on devait faire
essayer porte secours par en bas c'est
quoi la sueur c'est quoi la solution
moi j'ai proposé des choses jeudi et le
monde sait qui est qui donne en
développement d'asie
juste un mètre cinquante et une porte
c'est qu on peut prendre ça mon cher il
est grand il peut prendre les mêmes
vingtaine veine trentaine d'autres
personnes ils ont dit non c'est pas une
très bonne idée parce que le monde ça
fait le bruit et les principes et venez
nous attendre la sortie de monza ils
n'ont pas voulu monter au braquage d'un
bail à quai des personnes qu'ils ont
décidé monter là-haut à ma présence
quand ça monte moi c'est avec des
clients et comment s'appelle le web des
clients vous aviez qu'est-ce qui est son
préféré
ils disaient qu'ils ont ils préfèrent
rester en bas qui est monté là où le dit
c'est comme ça c'est le moment qu'ils
aient coupé le moteur parce que souvent
on coupe le moteur pour délivrer ce soir
il nous demande la paix voilà j'ai coupé
le moteur j'ai fait rentrer dedans je
disais bon vous me rendre là vous mettez
votre téléphone en vibration au moins
d'avions
après moi je disais que je vais prendre
sa place à personne même disais mais
pourquoi vous faites ça faut pas mettre
votre vie intense et s'est dit bien des
âmes notre vie à les désarmer lancé il
faut trouver la solution il faut qu'on
essaie de trouver la solution
moi je pouvais pas rester ici quand même
qu'est ce que vous en êtes sortis
comment quand il dit ça ils ont en effet
fermé que moi ça fait dans un ensemble
ouais moi j'ai appelé moi savent l
ascenseur à cet endroit se connaît pas
aller trop vite parce que moi je croise
était c'était des frères kouassi qui
sont rentrés dans les mandats la corse
qui essaie d'aider ferez quoi c'est
qu'ils ont été beaucoup médiatisé un
succès avant de connaître
coulibaly quand j'appelais mon sens il
était dans le magasin 710 musique assez
pour voir l'intérieur si c'est qu'à soi
disant quand j'ai regardé avait personne
à pied c'est vrai qu'à mon père mon
coeur qui bat et je sais pas si je vais
tomber sur lui ça faisait longtemps que
le monte-charge montée du sous sol
directement vous ne sortiez dans la rue
n'ont pas de l'arrêt d'un magasin dans
le magasin si les tories s'il en face
des mois d'arrêt et il arrive en charge
par rapport à ce qu'on peut observer
dans le magasin il ya une petite locales
souvent remettez les cartons la
boissière on a pris deux cartons de m
voilà si tu sors des monte-charges juste
un médecin quand ça donne notre second
porte sur coup ça donne aussi
le périphérique voilà donc là vous avez
réussi à sortir voilà qu'en sortie de
regarder un magot ça doit dévoiler ne
doit pas sous fond c'est vers la porte
après ses 16 ans que les avenues qui
disait qu'il a entendu quand je sors
d'où il est parti en courant pour savoir
ce qui s'est passé est une union quoi il
a vécu ils sont six mois a donc ça s'est
joué à quelques secondes
heureusement même cela après que poser
la question était heureusement même que
peut-être les aimons passive et oui s'il
m'avait suivi parce que c'est suffisant
qu'ils sont derrière moi ou si ses
supérieurs je prends la balle ce sera la
date en bon fait d'être tout seul ça
vous ça vous assurez la voilà tout cela
parce que c'est vrai que j'aurais que
vous vous saviez retourne pas moins de
charges
vous avez entendu tout ce monde cherche
à lui tout est enfin lui personnellement
que duvalier entendu le moins de charges
et s'est précipité vers là il s'est
précipité vers la porte et il m'a dit de
blé barré cadets avant de mettre la
farine mais s'ils avaient entendu
quelqu'un sortir tout de suite ils ont
entendu quelqu'un qui sont plus là et
après il est revenu il m'a dit c'est
jeudi que c'était la sortie c'est un
parking vous êtes dehors il ya les
policiers rient mahdi l'imam a fait
remettre la barre de fer qui était par
terre ce qui l'avait enlevée je sais pas
s'ils l'avaient enlevée mais était par
terre gelée romy je vais faire mais j'ai
pris la palette de farine les palettes
leyrolles cegetel d'aller tous rapports
après la saga aujourd'hui vous faites
pas aujourd'hui à cerner ce que vous
avez réussi à vous remettre de ce drame
ouais c'est dire c'est c'est à dire mais
comment épeler fonctions un peu plus
vite
je crois qu'il serait c'est la maison
liste se dément pas et moi c'est les
fonctions donc j'arrive à vivre
normalement aujourd'hui c'est d'excusés
c'est difficile et un moment c'était
bien mais depuis que les processeurs que
moi c'est encore impossible de dormir la
nuit
mon doigt in air désolé désordre
d'étendre la nuit après pourquoi vous
vous vous voyez les images vous on voit
les images et en même temps aussi
les procès d'être entouré dé commencer
les complices c'est si difficile c'est
difficile à vivre et vu comme ça on
avait même essayé d'en c'est pour ça que
je me suis témoigner au tribunal pour en
parler pour pouvoir sortir ce qui aux
nationaux parce que pour moi c'est
important d'en parler ça vous a fait du
bien moi ça m'a un peu explosé
ça m'a soulagé vous en avait parlé à
jean luc qui voulait pas totaliser pas
la liste des favoris avec cool avec
convaincu base de convaincre un passé où
il avait coorganisé par les sarries
aussi d'arriver à parler au bon milieu
de personnes du magasin ribas est
important lui qui vous a convaincu donc
le j'ai vu beaucoup de gens parler de
réseautage donc voilà au début c'est pas
prêt à partir
maintenant je vais en parler bon je
pense je pense finalement je change
d'avis d'y aller pour en parler parce
que ça fait du bien d'en parler